get rid of solo que for too long Riot's
refusal to let the league Community just
play ranked with their friends has
turned the game mode into a lonely toxic
hellscape in which communication is
constantly being limited and for what
just so you can say that you earned your
rank all by yourself look I have a ton
of thoughts on this and presumably so to
you so let's iron them out once and for
all
okay so we all know that in just about
any team oriented Esports ranked is just
about the most miserable player
experience anyone can have solo Q is in
no uncertain terms the principal cause
of virtually every grievance anyone has
ever had with any ranked system ever I'm
serious whether your teammates are bad
rude idiotic intake or actual bigots the
one commonality they all share is this
they weren't your first choice in fact
they weren't your choice at all they
were riots or some other game developers
why am I soliloquizing like this well
because several weeks back Riot made the
staggeringly hilarious decision to make
it so that in League of Legends your
teammates cannot see certain pings
they've since made adjustments as to
which pings are visible but the general
consensus was and continues to
be what wait so if I ping my support I
can see my pings but he can't see them
so what the's the point am I just going
to talk to myself about myself to myself
they've changed the Ping so now if I
ping a teammate only I can see it see
it's a self
ping but dude the guy is not paying
attention I can't ping him he doesn't
see it he doesn't have items we're all
telling him as much as they're going to
remove the pings from being able to spam
ping I feel like the the players are
just going to find something else to do
now for those who don't know there is
ostensibly a good reason to want to
stifle certain ping in League of Legends
the bait ping for instance had
infamously started to be misused as a
way for extremely toxic players to
deride other players given its initial
resemblance to a noose you can ping me
if you want there's a lot of new PS now
you can use bait ping which I know a lot
of people use for different
reasons the is of course is that actual
well-intended Allied pings were
suffering as a result but this is all
just symptomatic of a larger issue which
is that riots have slowly turned ranked
solo que into a single player video game
you pick a role Q ranked by yourself or
with at most one friend load into a
server where there are no voice coms no
pings and no shits given for any lane or
position that is not your own it is a p
PVE video game and for some reason the
community wants that for those who don't
know Riot have made changes to the
ranked infrastructure over the years
removing solo q and wanting to remove
Duo q and then reinstating solo Q
because the community wh and Riot were
huge cowards and acquiesced and yeah
it's a nightmare it always has been
essentially the community has become so
accustomed to the misery and despair of
having to earn one's rank all by oneself
that they started whining at the
prospect of actually having to play
League of Legends the way it was
intended to be played they had this idea
that unless your rank involved hurting
cats and baiting brain dead aaliis it
somehow didn't count and some of you
watching this video are probably
longtime league players and maybe you've
been indoctrinated with this way of
thinking here's the thing though you're
wrong because you are the only ones who
insist that it' be done this way ranked
in Dota 2 for instance a game in which I
have roughly 6,000 hours used to be
split into solo and party q and for many
years of my life the better part of a
decade it was the worst thing that had
ever happened to me csgo and CS2 premere
face it Rainbow Six Siege OverWatch even
Destiny all of these games allow you to
cue the quote unquote real ranked mode
with your friends and ear
actual ELO and in none of those game
modes does anyone tells me to myself
because I opted for a full clear on
jarvin but I don't have any friends to
play with you might say then make sense
I'm not trying to be mean I'm not I just
do not think that the entire player base
has to suffer racist sexist ining
idiotic teammates all because I have
someone to play with and you don't
that's insane and in no way worth it now
some of you who don't play league and
God bless you might be thinking why not
just play Flex Q why play solo Q because
Flex Q is quite frankly a meme it's a
joke no one takes it seriously and the
only way to fix that is to meld solo q
and flex Q together here's the other
thing though and a lot of league players
are not going to want to hear this but
it's the truth solo que is already also
a joke aside from League because
again why would you ever take leag
ranked seriously I am Diamond equivalent
or higher in virtually all of the
multiplayer esport titles I play I know
most people probably know me as like the
Cs guy but I actually have quite a wide
ranging experience with different rank
systems and how to climb them and I can
tell you beyond a shadow of a doubt that
league is the worst and that it's not
even close the only sensible way to play
league ranked and the only reason I play
it is to treat it as a seasonal event
that you play once now twice a year to
get a Victoria skin with the cool chroma
you want and then immediately stop
playing because you refuse to hate
yourself and the bulk of humanity in the
name of a video game in no way shape or
form does solo Duo Hue engender actual
competitive gameplay it doesn't at all
it is a form of online gambling if I
want to play actual League I cue Norms
with a five stack so again is it stupid
that Riot are stifling communication to
the point of non-existence yes certainly
but what's even stupider is that none of
this would be necessary if they just let
me play the game mode that's supposed to
matter with the people that I want to
play with just like they did in valerent
3 years ago Riot finally released
another competitive multiplayer title
that replicated this exact
infrastructure and yes there are
problems there are problems with every
ranked system it is an inherently
imperfect player experience but valerant
rank is leagues better than League the
difference is that in valerant you don't
have over 10 years of Stockholm syndrome
handcuffing Riot and making it
impossible for them to create any sort
of meaningful change in a hopelessly
miserable player experience the league
Community has become so accustomed to
the link between ranked and despair that
they can't recognize one without the
other they refus to accept the idea that
if your rank didn't come at the expense
of youring Sanity it can't count for
anything install loocking some meta
jungler muting all of your teammates
from the get-go and churning out games
like their hands of Solitaire doesn't
make you good at League it makes you
good at solo queue and those are very
different things in Counter Strike
however I can do my Premier placements
with a five stack play coordinated
communicative matches is that mirror
pretty much exactly how I'd play in esca
league and come out with an 80% win rate
the best you can hope for in league is
like a static 55 to 60% win rate and
that is if you are measurably better
than the players in the rank in which
you're situated why because of all of
the external factors that you are
susceptible to when you solo Cube like
teammates who are bad teammates who feed
teammates who are rude teammates pretty
much just teammates yeah that's the
issue and the reason that all of this is
genuinely so frustrating is because it
seems like that's what Riot wants like
they know that it is exceedingly more
difficult to climb as a solo queer and
so they force you to do it so you will
have to play hundreds of games a season
just to reach a high rank if Riot were
to just remove solo Duo and meld it
together with flex Q I swear to God they
would solve like 80% of the problems
that they are currently struggling with
right now with this ping crap they're
treating a bullet wound with a Band-Aid
they're treating the symptom not the
cause treat the cause please because
honestly and I'm just going to say it it
is unacceptable how toxic and miserable
League of Legends ranked has actually
become I mean it it's not funny anymore
I've been playing mobas seriously for
the better part of 15 years and I do not
know anyone who continues to grind
League of Legends ranked or take it
seriously in any way this game mode has
become world renowned for creating some
of the most toxic players in gaming and
I genuinely think that on some level
Riot should be ashamed that they are
allowing it to Fester to this degree
anyway that's my rant League ranked
sucks hard everyone knows it and they've
all given up trying to wrestle with it
and there's a very easy way to make
serious Headway in fixing it stop
messing around with pings and just Purge
solo Q from the face of summoner's rift
why the league Community is so opposed
to such a solution speaks volumes to how
resentful and genuinely traumatized
they've become over the suffering
they've endured they're convinced that
because they had to literally hate
themselves to reach the rank they
wanted we all have to as well if this
type of solution is good enough for
virtually every other multiplayer
competitive title out there it's good
enough for you guys it's good enough for
League of Legends so please give it some
thought let me know what you think in
the
[Music]
comments